RESERVING THE  OBJECT,
WE SHOULD AL VERY, VERY EAR.S O
ON NO
NORIGHHTE HOUSREPRESENTATIVES W
TWO-THDSY HE
$600 P ADULT T PER
ADULT.
HOUSE DITEM
E FOR THE O STEPES
WANT O DOMADAM IDA RESULT
THE PANDEMICS S OFAMERICANS HAV
THER FACREUT OUT
STREETS.
E HIGHT  HAS BEEN FOR DECADES WE
EMY FOOD PACKAGES.
AN  CERY STORE SHOPLIFTING A
S P
THEIMILIES FROM GOING
HUNGRY.
WEALTHIEST COUNTRY IN
HISTORY OF THEM PRESIDENT, OR T
REMARYBODY IN AMERI KNOWS,
TAX BREAKS
WE C
WHICISONAVE MOWEALTHNEQUALITY T
IN FACT, ITH THIS IBLE PANDEMIC
WEALTH IASDRED
LLS WHILE
AVERAGE AMERO
PUODN THE TABLE.
COVING TAX BREAKS TOE CORPORNSSE
TAXES.E, RPORATIONS IAMY Y ZERO
WE HE
MILITARY BUDGET IN THE HISTO
ISESWHILE, O MILLION OST NO BOUE
AMERICANS ARUNINSURE EPREDD
DE
PANDEMIC AND NOT SURIF THEY
CAFORD TO GO T.
PRESIDENT, WNGTO THE CLOONE  TT
EOPLFR C WE SPEAK WEEING RECORB
AN OF OF YOUNG PEOPLE FROMCARE S
HAS BEEN DISRUPTEDRRAL
TO SPEND TIME WITH THEIRAMILOR
,
SUICIDE.
MADAM PRESIDUSE HA THE RIGHTING.
BY VOTE,S D TED ASE THAT0 DIRECE
K THAT WAS
T DECISION.
THEY WANHE OUR C, UM-ELECT
BIDEADER CHUCKSCHUMER, SPEAKER T
WT
THIS ST MOM
RN BACKS WORKINGAIN?MADAM SER MA
ANE ONASVOTE  THE VET, SIDERATIR
CONSIDER BE D LATATEASD,
>> ITHN TOFO? OT.
IREO
ORIGINAL
>> I OEC
>>ECTION I
UNDER EVIOUSER, TH
A PERIOD O
>> MAM PRESIDENT?NU
PRESIDENT, THIS IS
W DESPERATE PEOPLEARE.
WE C HOW DURING THIS
HOLISEASON PEOPLE AROK PRO IE TH
ACTUALLY INFLICTED UPON OUR PUBT
>>N LAUREN
ING ALL OFS FROMTOL HIS.
WE HEA APERHAPS WEXPTHERE THE S
AID ONEDE
VOTING.T SAY VETO
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THE BIG NEWSS ON SMULUCH.S WHERE
BETWEEN DEMOCRATS AND
US CHEFR H
$600 TO $2,000
ION HOW TO PUT THE
PRESSUREN REBLS
I WANT TO BACK WHAT NNL E FLOOR.
O LUS  DIDN'RIHA CLAIR
CHECKS.
W
SCHUMER ASK
FOUNS CONSEN
LOXPFAIL, ANY D , YOU
SAW McCONNELL DO
S ECK BILL.
S NO CLL GO UPNE
SANDE
INDEPENDENT FROM VERMONT, SANGOO
CKS.AGAIN, McCONNELL SAID I AM T
ESSENTIALLJEG TO BERNIE SANDERSD
WE ARE STILL IN LIMBO T WE'RE GN
THE SENATEE $2,000HECKS.
A R THITHING PRESIDENT DONALD U
WANTTOTH
OVER THESEVERA SEEN KELLY LOEFF
STOF GEORGRUNOFF N  NEXEK,  W